[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
juan
hungrybox debedma has always lived in
the shadows
he lived in the shadow of his father who
never supported him
he lived in the shadow of the smash
community who turned him into a villain
he lived in the shadow of other players
who were always
just ahead of him both in terms of game
play
and tournament placings take seconds
hungrybox home for hungrybox but through
it all
he never gave up on being the best and
proving everyone wrong
he never gave up on himself or on smash
this is his story
hungrybox was born on june 21st 1993
in buenos aires argentina but he didn't
stay there for long
he was the youngest of three brothers
and his parents
juan daniel and lucia lived a somewhat
charmed life
in their home country but much of that
came crashing down
in 1994 when argentina was hit by a
recession
after mexico devalued its peso banks
collapsing
and investors pulling out of the
country's developing business
the debedma family made their way to
orlando florida
in search of a brighter future much of
the family fit
in fine but juan daniel didn't
by all accounts he didn't love the
change in lifestyle
and that triggered his temper juan
daniel grew angrier
and became obsessed with money he spent
money
ran out of money then went back to
argentina to try it all over again
by 2009 he was ready to leave his family
again
this time for the last time for i mean
for most kids
even for me there definitely was like a
lot of like rough stuff
but honestly the last when he left for
the very last time and it was just made
my butt as my mom
it was like the biggest relief in the
world it's just like i can go home
and i can you know do my homework now
without the sounds of huge yelling in
the background i can like
just chill and know i don't have to
worry about anything anymore you know it
was a lot more time to focus
on just me without juan daniel in their
life
the young de biedma brothers were
supported by their mother lucia
who hungrybox credits with just about
everything
i definitely spent a lot more time with
my mom because i didn't want her to be
lonely i guess
and from that i guess we have built a
really strong like mother-son
relationship
so like we're really close today people
say they're dealt different hands in
life some kids are born with a silver
spoon in their mouth some kids are born
being the heir to huge fortune or for
royalty i was born with the best mom in
the world so like
i owe her everything as his home life
became a little more stable
hbox began to explore the world of
competitive melee
and his first tournament a monthly at
gigabits land center
in florida inspired him to make his
jigglypuff
into the best in the world my first real
tournament was gigabits
2007 near ucf it was a land center
and they had a first official legit
tournament with two out of threes
a bracket system low tier tournaments
man the rush
i still remember to this day the rush of
walking in the russia seeing top players
compete it's unlike anything else it's
such
an amazing experience for me i was
hooked from the first day i walked in
hungrybox placed ninth there an
impressive result for his first
real tournament but it just inspired him
to grind
i was playing every day with my friends
there's this group of players called
wado what are the odds in the orlando
kissimmee area
and they kind of took me in as their
underling and taught me all the
match-ups and i played with them every
day and i would host them at my house
my parents house every friday would have
this thing called box fests
in my you know cramped bedroom that
the ac was not working so it's like 80
degrees in there so
it was just funny because like those
moments are like really what
molded my understanding of match-ups in
those early days
melee's competitive scene was
disorganized and scattered
hungrybox wasn't part of melee's first
golden age
when the game was played on mlg's
circuit and players like ken
pc chris and isaiah ruled the scene
instead he rose to prominence in the
dark ages of melee
and while he made his national debut at
revival of melee
hungrybox credits genesis as the
tournament that jump-started his pro
career
genesis was the biggest melee tournament
at the time
and it attracted america's finest most
eyes were on mango
who was considered one of the best melee
players in the world at the time
and armada europe's top smasher who came
to make a name for himself
n a but flying under everyone's radar
was hungrybox
who tore through the bracket losing only
to mango
later that year hungrybox attended
revival of melee 2
and finally made his name truly known
[Applause]
following a slew of second place
finishes apex 2010 the following year
marked his next national victory but he
wasn't consistently dominating the
competition
when it counted in fact he didn't see
another major first place finish again
until 2013. oh he wants to
take it grab he's going for the up air
falls down gets the shield
stabbed pins him on the edge and
clutches out with that up air
mango is your grand finals champion for
big house too
the fly guy gets hit from both
characters
hungry uh armada with a very very wise
using a second jump
yeah and he gets shield stabbed
all right up there closes it out and
sins
hungrybox home and hbox was a
disappointment
he came to this tournament uh oh
wow we got a we got a sad box here
hungrybox learned melee on jigglypuff
who at first glance
doesn't exactly seem like one of the
game's more potent characters
jigglypuff has been in smash since the
franchise's inception
but was put in the game as something of
a joke
she's slow doesn't do much damage and
most of her special moves have severe
downsides if you miss them but hungrybox
was drawn to her
as a kid his hobby was trying to beat
everything in melee's single-player
modes
and as he futilely tried to beat
all-star mode without dying
he discovered puff's rest move i was
missing like 20 trophies or whatever
one of them was beat all-star mode on
very hard without
dying or whatever or so i thought and so
i tried doing it i kept losing kept
losing i'm like which character in this
game can restore hp i'm like wait a
minute
jigglypuff can do that because she has
rest i'm pretty sure
in pokemon that means you were store hp
and i remember i used it for the first
time and it's just
this useless [ __ ] move does zero
percent you're just
stuck there i'm like she's the worst
kicker in the game and i
went an hour later and i'll tell this to
everyone had this not happened i
wouldn't be here today i was walking
down the hall to the bathroom
i turned to the right my brother's room
he happened to be playing smash 64.
and right as it looked he landed a rest
with puff in that game
i looked at it and i was like whoa i'm
like how'd you do that
he's like yeah she just has a downbeat
that changed everything i would have
never known i would have never know what
that move did
in his earliest days of competition
mango made his name on jigglypuff
and innovated much of her early
playstyle
but by the time hungrybox was rising to
prominence in the early 2010s
jigglypuff's star was fading fox and
falco's dominance in that era of melee
was a nightmare for puff players who
died very quickly to their powerful
upwards ko moves
and had difficulty dealing with
projectiles but hungrybox persevered
playing jigglypuff runs contrary to just
about
everything a casual spectator knows
about melee
she's not fast her combos tend to be
rather short
and she's extremely floaty making her
easier to kill
but she's not without her strengths that
rest kill that hungrybox learned about
as a kid
is at the very center of what makes puff
so powerful
but until she finds the hit you have to
play extremely patiently
working to get your opening that level
of patience
has grown to define hungrybox i would
say hunger box
have very very good patience he
he has a game style and he's never
forfeiting that game style
at any cost pretty much uh he's not
going for like risky stuff he's going
for whatever he thinks is
the most practical option a lot of times
he's always like you kind of know what
he's gonna do but it's what he's doing
is very safe so it's like
like you see it coming but it's like i
can't really do much about it right now
so it's all about picking your spots
with him
and him he's kind of more of probably
more of an annoying player just the way
he plays
and if you start getting annoyed by it
that's when he starts shining that's
like when he gets in your head
already known as one of the best in the
world hungrybox finally pulled out of
his slump in 2013
and won norcal regionals beating mango
in the grand finals
yeah oh my goodness you can't afford oh
this might just doesn't still
have his job
[Applause]
he followed that up with a shocking
third place finish at evo
2013 which will go down in history as
one of melee's most stacked tournaments
ever
there he beat s fat
boom off
in fact hbox only lost to wobbles and
mango the two players who faced off in
the grand finals
hbox continued to display strong form
for the next few years
placing second at the big house three
all right
he's not in a good spot right now i'll
tell you ladies and gents both both
states will be back here
west west it's over
third at ceo 2014. and music
does have a gun so he might try to rack
up a lot of damage with these lasers and
then wait for the right time
tonight that is it good night second at
evo 2014.
he cannot train and make go why not take
it yet he goes for the upper throw up
here this time it hits
and we have our champion mango first
place here at evolution
2014 for super smash brothers
and finally first place at paragon
orlando 2015
yeah the mistake of the reach yeah that
was yeah was that about smashing each
game
um i was definitely looking at oh
oh he's way up there and he takes it
beautiful job hungrybox
beats music and yet again he can't
believe it a 3-0 victory
over one of the best smash players
period
[Music]
is uh what determines i don't know if
you can hear this in my headset but like
listen to the crowd
yeah the crowd is not happy
[Applause]
everybody says what are you gonna do
it's just like like a dark kind of like
please do you see how i won that game
there is something of a gap
between juan de biedma and hungrybox
throughout 2015 hungrybox was arrogant
brash and cocksure he knew he was one of
the best and he wasn't afraid to play
the heel
to a crowd full of haters
the patient play style that hungrybox
developed to make the most of
jigglypuff's strong kill option and her
slow
floaty movement meant walling opponents
out
which meant playing slow games that
often had long periods of movement
with no real action which meant people
weren't exactly rushing to watch
hungrybox play
but the community's animosity spread
further than that
hungrybox's slow play style combined
with his over-the-top heel persona
led to plenty of hate from the smash
community
and as their hatred grew it began to
make hungrybox
question if he should continue playing
but
like all things in his life his mom
found a solution
i wanted to quit a lot of times
especially when i was like in that weird
transition phase where i was trying to
figure out who i am
between the ages of like 18 and 21 i was
just like man
so many people hate me why am i doing
this and people ate me i'm not getting
any satisfaction from this
and i was yeah i was really gonna quit
uh
but i think louis my mom [ __ ] me out
of it hungrybox didn't just rub the
community the wrong way at times
he also tended to turn some pros against
him as well
hungrybox and mango have clashed several
times in game
but after mango's evo 2013 win
their rivalry spilled out into the
internet where the two traded barbs on
reddit
but it's his relationship with leffen
that has remained somewhat heated
all your [ __ ] talk get [ __ ] leffen i
don't care
who ended up winning leffen where are
you now where are you now
i want to kick that guy's ass i would be
lying if i
you know didn't really want to [ __ ]
beat his ass and i want to make sure
that when i do it
he remembers what happened to him at
summit
last time he talked [ __ ] and got blown
up absolutely possible for fox to just
you know
find an upsmash and tie everything up
but yeah all right
game 500 winning uh with i gotta say
you know it's feeling left is off the
stage hundred bucks it's a mad dog
wow it's a mad dog wow oh
hungrybox spent much of 2015 without a
significant win
after paragon orlando he was winning
smaller events but
when there was more than one god in
attendance hungrybox was taking
second third even fifth but he finally
rounded the corner on the last stretch
on his road to the top
when he won dream hack winner 2015.
pretty much immaculate to not get hit by
right now but man hbox
when armada plays the platforms hbox is
all over him i think that is it
congratulations to hungrybox
making history here on european soil he
is now
the first place singles champion for
super smash brothers melee
here at dreamhack winner 2015
and after his victory he broke down
his father who had told him he'd never
amount to anything
and left his family behind was gone
and hungrybox was finally on his way to
the top
d1 i've wanted this for so long
and you know my my dad just passed away
you know
it was my biological dad and we i know
his personal stuff but he told me
you'll never be the best you'll be good
but you'll never be the best
so i hope he sees me now despite a small
slip at genesis 3
2016 was a banner year for hbox
first at battle of the five gods pound
2016
eglx and ceo 2016
put hungrybox in the conversation for
the best player in the world
[Music]
and then came evo all through 2016
there was really only one person who
could challenge hungrybox
armada armada was europe's best and
by most accounts the greatest melee
player in the world
but hungrybox was learning how to beat
him thanks in part to his coach
crunch crunch was a long time friend and
was even one of those people that got
him into competitive melee
we thought we were hot [ __ ] we thought
we could like beat anyone we're like
yeah we'd be all our friends we're great
at this game we watch like tournament
videos we're like you know what these
guys are good we can probably be as good
as them
so that's kind of where it all started
but crunch was also the analytical mind
behind hungrybox's success
he helped him put together the
strategies he needed to bring down
players
like armada he was also the guy who
helped hbox
translate that patience he learned from
his family life
to his play style well here in person
like right before match is all about
mentality and warming up making sure
that all the stuff that we worked on is
uh
it's fresh that he's ready to go into
the match outside of that it's really
like
going into the lab like figuring out new
strategies making sure that everything's
really really clean
um and going over his opponents and
analyzing the matches to make sure we
have a good strategy going into the
matches
if dreamhack winter was a coming out
party for hbox's optimal play style
then evo was where he showed off exactly
how
optimal it was show us what you got
yesterday run away okay
that backer wall right now he's just
zoning him out is that gonna be a rest
no carries him off stage instead oh no
spotting that double jump and uh moving
on i think these players could win this
whole tournament they're facing off
this is the last game
right now you know we talked about how
he does now he's turning around
there's the wrong match he does not get
the tech
hbox sending mangle out of the
tournament in fourth place
oh no i didn't it's not even really a
rhyme
yeah yeah yeah all right you know that
hundred bucks can you take
that 100 take this nugget
[Applause]
will now be facing off yeah in the grand
finals of people 2016.
it's like we're back in 2015 where
almost every grand finals are about a
hundred bucks yes
here we are we're gonna see them duke it
out one more time
hbox drew first blood taking the first
two games
back to back but armada struck back with
two games of his own
with everything on the line hungrybox
clutched it out to reset the bracket
with the rest heard around the world
the pressure's on playing around each
other right now armada
not giving him anything nobody gets hit
he
[Applause]
this time the two traded games back and
forth
but hungrybox closed it out
who's here this is big
he recovers german the tournament winner
the emotion of winning the biggest melee
tournament ever with all eyes on him
overwhelmed him he fell to the floor and
cried
he was finally the best
[Applause]
a few months after evo 2016 hungrybox
quit his full-time job
to focus on smash i've quit my job at
west rock
i've quit my job at west rock and i'm
going to play melee for the next few
years
i'm going to travel around the world and
i'm going to visit
all my fans in tournaments
for years hungrybox had been balancing
smash and school
and then smash and his engineering job
but after years of waiting
smash was finally big enough to support
him
the way he needed once again his
patience was rewarded
armada and hungrybox went back and forth
for the rest of the year
even agreeing that the winner of smash
summit 3 would be the best player in the
world
it's so scary because this kind of
reminds me of jaws
but 2017 was when hbox shined
first at dreamhack austin
it's incredible it's literally
unwinnable as much as things change
they stay the same god damn that second
place
hungrybox first ceo 2017.
really hard to play this high level
melee this late at night
yeah and that's harassed and that is it
hungrybox is your ceo 2017
champion and perhaps most notably smash
summit five
where he broke armada's four summit
streak how is armada playing like a
normal human right now how is he a top
level player with all this stress
i can't even think he lives
and hungrybox ends the armada streak he
is yours
the best super smash brothers melee
player in the world
all that together finally put hungrybox
on top
he moved from second to first in the
world rankings
pushing armada off the top for the first
time since 2015
and he's remained strong attending a
tournament nearly every week in 2018
and either winning or getting close
every time
he's finally made it out of the shadow
of jigglypuff
of armada of the community that loves to
hate him
his patience has finally paid off
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you